he's Rich Eisen NFL Network host the
Rich Eisen show he joins us now what do
you remember remember about that
Herschel Walker deal oh gosh I remember
it was shocking that that number one
that the Cowboys would trade their top
talent like that and then it would get
so much back for him and then I do
remember the the answer was in the same
part of the question was the same way
that we're looking at the the current
Browns in a way is just like okay now
you have all these draft picks you have
to catch them into actual human beings
to win how will you be able to do that
and just obviously with Paulie
mentioning Emmett Smith you could have
pretty much stopped their throws Darren
Woodson into the mix and you know and
being a teammate of Michael Irvin's as
I've been for a few years he will you
will mention that every now and then as
is you know a big moment as well for the
team when they were building it with him
and how huge that was but in all honesty
you know it is still a quarterback
driven league and without a command none
of that would have happened so the fact
that they got the first overall pick in
the process with Aikman put it all
together and you got yourself a dynasty
speaking of quarterbacks here's our poll
question make loving give the poll
question to rich brought you my travel
Jim if you could have either these two
cubes for the next five years went or
Newton who do you got
I do went Cam's taking too many hits too
many heads I mean look last week was
tremendous for Cam Newton to go into
Detroit for a big game where the winner
emerges four and one with a nice big
huge step forward in the conference that
is wide open
certainly coming off the week that he
had maybe he was maybe he was weighed
down by all the yogurt so yogurt free he
went in through three touchdowns and
three hundred some-odd yards one of his
best games but went is younger young
wenches not taking as many hits although
Lane Johnson is out tonight I am
genuinely concerned about that I would
take one still yeah that's the majority
would take wins as well
I don't know what wins can become I know
what cam can become can he sustain that
but you know he's played at an MVP
caliber level winning it as rookie year
was one of the great rookie seasons
we've ever seen with the quarterback it
feels like Carson Wentz's high may not
be as high as Cam Newton but as low is
not going to be as low as cam I don't
know I mean you look at what once is
done with now two different completely
offensive personnel sets and he just
keeps winning and now last year he went
2 and 8 with Lane Johnson out when
Johnson had a 10 game suspension and it
was a big difference now when Johnson
went out in the second half of the game
against the Cardinals last week went
just kept on keeping on and that might
be you know more of an indication of
what was going on with the Cardinals in
that game you know we'll find out
tonight I'm really really looking
forward to tonight it's it's got all it
hits all the buttons with the record
obviously your poll question indicates
the or the high level of interest in
both of these quarterbacks playmakers
that are on fantasy teams all over the
place I'm really fired up for tonight
how do you explain what's going on with
the Pittsburgh Steelers well I took a
look at it
just yesterday as a matter of fact and
they're not running the ball defensively
they are as good as anybody they're
they're number one in passing defense I
don't believe you're going to be able to
throw very very well on them the Chiefs
though certainly should be able to run
the ball on them and and levy on bells
gotta get going I think it is it is just
maybe just maybe an indication of the
fact that he held out and he's still
trying to get his sea legs under him and
the whole team is just a little bit off
kilter because they haven't had enough
time to to be together even though you
know the big three has been together and
you know they've got Bryant back they
should be fine I think they lose in
Kansas City they're three and three
there'll be a lot of hand-wringing but
after that I think though they'll put
their foot in the ground and start
winning some games and win that
vision thanks for that defense because
the offense is only going to have to get
better but they're just not running it
levy on bail just 14 carries last week
against the Jacksonville team that was
punked him just absolutely punked him so
I do believe like I said three and three
there'll be a lot of hand-wringing
but they'll be fine after that he's Rich
Eisen the NFL Network owes toast of the
Rich Eisen show an audience Channel 239
that follows this one Jeff Bridges the
Academy award-winning Jeff Bridges will
be on the program today
the big lebowski yes we'll definitely
talking about that I love that movie it
was on the other night it's a remote
drop for me and it's it's from from John
Goodman to John Turturro and Buscemi and
then you know him as the Big Lebowski
but I also want to talk to about his dad
who was you know an airplane and is the
way I was watching the Yankees Indians
game last night I picked the wrong week
to stop drinking and smoking in
different nights but I just want to hit
him on his dad and his movies and you
know whatever sports he has because you
know that he knows you're gonna hit the
topic of the big lebowski right I think
so
now did you have is that one of those
because sometimes a PR person will say
hey whatever you do don't go there and
you go I want to go there
I can't yes then you're a veteran of the
interviewing business no doubt about it
some people don't like talking about
some of their old stuff but then some
just love it
some love it I I imagine any question
that doesn't have the words Harvey and
Weinstein in it is something he'll be
he'll be happy about so are you gonna
bring up Harvey Weinstein no no you I
don't even know if Jeff worked with
Harvey Weinstein yeah I mean I had Tyler
Perry on and I didn't ask him about
Harvey Weinstein oh I mean I mean it's
not in the in the in our world there
that I I'm not familiar with it I don't
want to have somebody telling a sports
audience about Harvey Weinstein yeah you
know so and that's why I think you know
shows like yours and in mine when the
celebrity comes on you talk a little
sports and some pop culture because to
me the
bow ski is as popular in our culture as
as sports it really is I mean you talk
to sports with somebody who loves the
Big Lebowski and it sounds it sounds the
same when you talk about passionately on
both subjects but as much as I love Jeff
Bridges I didn't like The Big Lebowski
oh I know I don't know why yeah
really have you watched it yes I'm tried
oh come on my trying Wow
I don't know and I and I think Jeff
Bridges is you know one of the great
actors we have of our generation and you
have the other supporting cast in there
John Goodman's great oh yeah you don't
roll on Shabbos I just it's not one of
my favorite movies and it's a little
disjointed it's a little bit psychedelic
from time to time it's it's it's out
there yeah it's out there if I had to go
my favorite Coen Brothers movie there
I'd go Raising Arizona yeah that would
be my favorite one with Nicolas Cage
Holly non-germans in that one too yes
yeah if I had to go if I'm a ranked the
Coen brothers de comedia I would go
Raising Arizona one bud simple is pretty
good blood simple I think my role would
be in that next - yeah I'd put Fargo up
there - Frances McDormand was was
awesome I'd lose you know no we're here
oh hello
tell rich that's what you get when you
say you don't like the Big Lebowski
that's what rich gets for you know
saying he loved The Big Lebowski that's
Richie just tell rich thank you
we're up against the break he's trying
to sway me
hello well rich is listening in his car
rich your your phone dropped out there
but thank you for joining us in Rich
Eisen show coming up at noon eastern
nine Pacific on audience Channel 239
with Jeff ridges and watch rich ask
questions about The Big Lebowski the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you